millions of people around the world
marched in what is being called the
largest climate protest ever teens
organized walkouts in more than a
hundred and fifty countries Friday many
were inspired by the Friday's for future
campaign led by 16-year old Swedish
activist Greta tun Berg some say they're
planning walkouts every Friday until
elected leaders make changes to protect
the environment this monday marks the
beginning of the United Nations climate
summit here in New York
according to recent polling by CBS News
56 percent of Americans said climate
change is something that needs to be
addressed now and climate change is the
sole focus of a new special issue by
Time magazine that is out now this
morning we are joined by Justin Warland
senior climate correspondent at time
Justin good morning so you write an
article about the political implications
of climate change and Iowa specifically
obviously a key in the primaries how is
this year different than other election
years when it comes to climate change
yeah well I spent a good amount of time
and I were talking to voters talking to
people about how they've been feeling
the effects of climate change right now
I've been feeling the effects of stream
extreme weather they've I used the line
if you throw a dart at a map of Iowa
you're likely to hit a place that's had
flooding and you know that leaves a that
leaves that impression for voters
particularly Democratic voters who are
who understand the science of climate
change they've been impacted more
recently so now it's more on top of
their minds exact are certain candidates
talking about it more than others I mean
certainly there are some who who are
talking about it a lot I mean jay Inslee
was in the race he devoted his entire
campaign to it but each candidate was
really grappling with how they're going
to speak about it one thing I found
really interesting you hearing the
Elizabeth Warren talk about climate
change she talks about it from the
perspective of you know corporations and
how do we get influence out so that we
can deal with this this this issue and
then others will talk about it you know
Kamala Harris will talk about it from
the perspective of suing polluters you
know something that she brings
experience from as a former attorney
general I want to talk about this youth
movement because if you look throughout
history certainly with the civil rights
movement
it was ignited by children children
absolutely how can this youth enthusiasm
spurned by Greta the sixteen-year-old
from Sweden push and sustain itself yeah
that's a that's a good question I mean I
think what's really interesting to me is
one obviously they're an inspiration to
everyone I mean I think for the climate
community for the people who deal with
these issues on a day to day basis this
is something that is a real bright spot
when the news can often be very grim but
I think is also really important as they
send a very big signal to corporations
to government officials who might be
lagging in their response that things
need to change that future generations
are not going to allow the same business
as usual approach and I think that's
going to sustain itself which goes to
Jeff's story and the question of whether
or not this generation will pay for the
sustainability of this planet yeah yeah
I mean that that that generation will be
on the they will experience the things
that generations pass to have
repercussions on what we've done to our
yeah and it won't be cheap is my point
there's there's the politics over them
it's a solution so this issue which
which goes around the globe the Time
magazine issue talks about six things
that may happen over the next thirty
years what they think need to happen
over the next thirty years that is
phased out natural gas and coal grow
renewables chart a path on nuclear
remove carbon from the atmosphere which
is what we talked about on the trees
peace support trees and the growth of
trees and make energy use more efficient
you really went all around the world for
this issue including this concept of
rewilding we see as well yeah absolutely
I mean one thing that I think you know
planting trees can sound very simple or
you know dealing with nature can sound
very simple but it's really at the heart
of this there was a paper in the journal
science earlier this year that found
that if we if we planted trees on an
area the size of US and China which
sounds like a lot but it's an area
that's ripe for trees growing we could
eliminate two-thirds of the emissions
that we've that we've had since the
Industrial Revolution that's a big thing
that will not happen
way but it has a huge potential okay
Justin Moreland thank you very much for
being here
thank you